what are some universal human rights
that you believe all people should have
so free speech
freedom of assembly
freedom of belief
freedom to participate in your
government
the freedom to have privacy the freedom
to own things property rights
these are all basic fundamental negative
rights what we call them
these are the basic fundamental human
freedoms
what does negative rights mean
negative rights are
liberties and positive rights are
entitlements
so after world war ii when the u.n came
together it was largely a compromise
between the communist soviet union and
the you know free united states right so
the u.s had
uh on its side of the u.n declaration of
human rights uh a bunch of
liberties essentially things like free
speech freedom of association freedom of
assembly the soviets wanted entitlements
uh like the right to work the right to
have housing the right to water the
right to a vacation so you actually read
the un declaration for human rights it's
a negotiation between the soviets and
the americans
later
there was another document in the 70s
released called the international
covenant on civil and political rights
and this is what ahref uses as it's sort
of like lodestar
its founding document and this is like
essentially an international agreement
on the negative rights those are the
things we choose to focus on because
essentially authoritarian regimes can
commit fraud and claim they're giving
the positive rights the entitlements
without having any of the negative
liberties and they can do that because
they don't have any like free speech or
press freedom um when you when you take
people's basic fundamental freedoms away
it's quite easy to make like a potemkin
village and pretend that there's the
entitlements and that we have good uh
healthcare and you know
it's the same sort of thing that
authoritarians have done for decades
cuba and venezuela and and the soviet
union do you think it's possible for
authoritarian regimes to manipulate to
kind of lie about the negative rights as
well by saying that the people have free
speech
the people have the freedom to for
assembly and all those kinds of things
can't you still manipulate
the idea that the citizenry still has
those rights
the opposition leader of malaysia anwar
ibrahim he once told me
uh
the funny joke that you know in my
country we have freedom of speech we
don't have freedom after speech
so yeah they can absolutely manipulate
whatever they want but i've done
research into socioeconomic data and i
guess what i'm telling you is that
authoritarian regimes which make up
uh 53 of the world's population across
95 countries
about 4.3 billion people
those who live under those regimes are
subject to
massive fraud when it comes to things
like literacy rates
life expectancy
any sort of socio-economic data economic
growth
they can do this because there's no free
press
so for us at the human rights foundation
and for people like me
we believe that the negative rights the
liberties the things that are in for
example uh the bill of rights in the us
constitution these things are the table
and then we can build on top of that we
can build the rest of our societies on
top of that the freest countries in the
world have both the negative liberties
and the entitlements like norway for
example but there's a big difference
between norway and north korea in north
korea they only claim to have the
entitlements and they definitely don't
have the liberties
do you think there's one right that's
more important than others you kind of
suggested the freedom of the press
maybe freedom of speech
that if you take that away all the other
ones kind of collapse along with like
from a ripple effect is there something
fundamental that you uh like to focus
your attention on to defend to protect
to make sure it's there yeah i think i
think free speech is probably the most
fundamental it's probably why the
founders chose to make it into the first
amendment um
a lot of things are downstream from
there property rights are also very very
important um
obviously we've seen the the toll of
violent redistributionism you know and
over the last hundred years
uh whether it was uh lenin or stalin or
mao
or other regimes and everywhere from
ethiopia to
colonial colonialists everywhere to
north korea it's not a pretty legacy
you